[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on Sakai on
very excited to be talking about
fundamental well being talking about the
finders we have dr. Jeffrey Martin
joining us on the show hello
hey thanks for having me it's great to
be here coming on all right absolutely
thanks for coming down to the conference
and doing all those videos you are like
working from 9:00 to 9:00 I just kind of
left you in your own space and then you
want to go in that room for fear I was
gonna interrupt something the
transformative technology ecosystem is
one of the most powerful that we've had
the chance to be a part of so we're very
grateful that we got to go down there
and do interviews that just happened in
November all of those interviews you
guys can find on the channel they're all
labeled with Transtech you can find the
playlist and and it's just awesome also
after researching your background
realizing how much you are at the edge
of understanding fundamental well being
for those that don't know dr. Jeffery
Martin is a founder of the
transformative technology space a serial
entrepreneur and at California Institute
of integral studies and Harvard educated
social scientists to research his
personal transformation and the states
of greatest human well-being
he has authored slash co-authored slash
edited more than two dozen books most
recently the finders which is the first
multinational cross traditional study on
over 1,000 plus people reporting to
experience higher levels of
consciousness I loved reading the book
we're gonna be talking about that in
depth you can find Jeffrey Martin's
links below and his Twitter and his
Facebook link below so go and check that
out in the book link Jeffrey let's start
things off on a big history perspective
we find ourselves as stewards of earth
what does your current take on the state
of humanity
that there's billions of them right I
mean there's so many different cultures
one of the things when you do a study
like ours and you go all around the
world you go across all of these
different cultures and subcultures and
whatnot is you realize just the massive
amount of diversity that's out there
presidential candidates always talk
about this you know I used to have a
walk back in the day I had a little
political consulting company and you
deal with these presidential candidates
who fer like the first time we're going
across America you know and they were
shaking hands and like every little
community of every little state or
whatever else and they were like oh my
god like there is no United States of
America it's just so diverse culturally
people are so different from one place
to another then you take that to a
global scale and it's really astonishing
and so I think of it more as regional
than global and so anyway so I don't
know it's a good question
I actually I really don't know I think
that's a difficult question to answer
you well I loved how you took us to the
eight billion different human
perspectives and their different
cultures all right yeah yeah cuz you're
right that you can go from the middle of
the United States and experience
something completely different than you
can on the metropolitan coasts the
melting pots out there and furthermore
go to China go to India South Africa go
to Latin America it's something
completely different everywhere think
about the difference between like San
Francisco where we are and Los Angeles
right I mean in San Francisco you go
into the richest neighborhoods and there
are like the dumb pious beat-up Priuses
and stuff that people are driving right
you go to Los Angeles and if your car's
more than a year old and it's not
spotless and how its shining and you
don't have a certain polish I mean it's
just I could it's inconceivable how
different these two worlds are and
there's seven hour drive apart from each
other on the left coast or whatever as
people say right and so even just that
level of diversity is kind of
astonishing yeah the diversity of social
stratification as well just a couple
miles away from
area in Los Angeles in that area in San
Francisco that you're talking of these
are richest area and totally we have the
the highest levels of homelessness yeah
yeah yeah absolutely yeah and all
different all different culture right
yes yes and all the way to where humans
are still using jerrican gallons and
walking to wells to get water to them so
we have versus a faucet so there is like
yeah this is very different in terms of
yet perspective it's important to get
behind the eyes of as many perspectives
as possible to have a comprehensive view
on that so we did four so-called higher
levels of consciousness you know we I
really wanted to know what's the truth
about these things at the core and
unless you get that 30,000 foot view and
then visit a bunch of places that you're
flying over you know you really can't
get it you've got a you've got a you
know so many people wants us oh no it's
this or oh no it's that or oh no it's
this other thing but it's like going to
you know the rich area a rich area in
San Francisco versus aporia in San
Francisco they both have this reality
they consider totally the truth right
and then to LA totally the truth in
hollywood hills versus santa monica even
you know so it's just it's a it's one of
those things where i think you have to
get the diversity of perspective in
order to get down to the real heart of
the matter and that's the only thing
that we were really after and all of our
research was what's at the heart of the
matter how do we pull out what's at the
absolute core of this experience i don't
want you know it was for me right i
didn't want to be fooled because i was
12 years ago or so you know fairly
successful but kind of average in terms
of happiness
you know i wasn't depressed or you know
i didn't have some sort of massive
existential crisis going on or something
like that but it just seemed like i was
working an awful lot and i'd done off a
lot of the stuff that people had told me
that i should do and yet i seemed like
there were people that were a lot
happier than I was that weren't doing
any of that and you know there was a
puzzle there I didn't want to keep doing
the same thing for the rest of my life
right and get the same mediocre result
and turn
of my moments a moment well being so
this whole thing this whole study all of
it was just for me and so I did not want
to have the wool pulled over my eyes I
do not want to go out and just believe
the 1st 2nd 3rd 4th 5th 10th 12th
population of people that were insisting
oh no this is what truth this is what it
is you know I wanted to scoop in as much
of that as I possibly could strip all of
the stuff that wasn't common off the top
of it and say what is the deeper reality
here that you need to go after yes yes
and this is great you're you go you give
us this perspective of going in behind
the eyes of so many people that are
experiencing these states of fundamental
well-being and then you're doing that
meanwhile retaining a 30,000 foot
perspective over what's happening
finding the commonality writing about it
in the finders let's let's um let's talk
about your journey that led you to
become who you are today so this was
actually very interesting when I learned
that it's been it's been 11 years now as
a director at the Center for the studies
of non symbolic consciousness as well as
a myriad of other things and longer than
that for the study because we didn't
start the center right away you know I
didn't have an understanding of the
political landscape of the Academy when
I was first starting out and so I didn't
know that it was a good idea to start a
center or to start a sort of a core
brand if you will within the Academy
that all the little things would lead
back to and so really it started in 2006
baby energy actually started even before
that because the book that God formula
came during a previous period of
research but people will ask me about
that research and it's been so long now
that I kind of have to watch my old
youtube videos and stuff to even sort of
remember what our findings were you know
and not like that super interesting to
me like they were back then because I'm
just in a different place you know but
if you if you think about that research
effort it was a very I think kind of
common sensical research effort because
what I basically did was say to myself
well there's a ton of people trying all
of these self-help products so we ought
to be able to go out and
search those people and research those
products and see if like some are better
than other ISM whatever else and I wound
up learning that most of them went in
the opposite direction of academic
research you know later on so you know
for instance if you're in positive
psychology if you're journaling about
your day
right well if you write just write a
journaling book generally you're gonna
provide one of a few pieces of
information right so just you know write
down you know the things that bothered
you and really sort of analyze them and
the things that made you happy and
really sort of analyze so there's the
analyze it sort of version of journaling
right and then there's the related
version of journaling right so just the
story you're reliving the story while
you're writing that down but it turns
out that neither one of those are
necessarily ideal so if you're
journaling about a negative event best
to analyze it if you're journaling about
a positive event and you analyze it
you'll probably make yourself less happy
interesting if you relive a positive
event in your journaling you'll make
yourself more happy yeah if you relive a
negative event less happy right and so
there were nuances like that and the
scientific literature that would just
sort of mist oftentimes by the public
authors you know and unfortunately now
we've had people like Sonja Lyubomirsky
talbin Shahar you know these sort of
Richard Wiseman you know hardcore sort
of researchers in the Academy that have
published books and but their books are
less popular than other people's books
because they're not out there promoting
them all the time and that's not what
they're rewarded for they're basically
punished if you're in the Academy you're
punished for writing a popular book
because your department says why aren't
you writing more peer-reviewed papers
right that's what we're ranked on as a
university right every minute that
you're not writing peer-reviewed papers
our rankings going down you know our
ranking could have been higher and so
you're it's it's this weird system sort
of out there so I what made a pass
through all of that and the research and
that was fantastic and it really left
off right at the door to fundamental
well-being it was like there was this
this whole batch of sort of a
progression that somebody could make and
that self-help literature if they did it
right and then there was just like this
wall well then it all ran into and I was
like took me a year to figure out what
that wall
was in that wall was just a completely
different way of experiencing the world
that today we would call fundamental
well-being or academically persistent
non symbolic experience or anecdotally
you know and enlightenment non symbolic
consciousness from our standpoint you
know persistent mystical the
consciousness unit of consciousness
there's hundreds of hundreds of terms
for this stuff you know could we could
we say that we are birthed into the
playground earth and kind of into the
social political economic machineries of
the world and that the the wall that
you're saw was this wall of the of being
fundamentally okay with being alive and
being able to yet we'll get into some of
yeah for sure so then so then now it's
like why it's basically the wall of
surrender you know that's like there's
just before that from a modeling
standpoint we're remodeling all that
back in the day there was a lot of
release type stuff very active in the
mind psychologic or release type of
stuff you know EMDR and whe standing for
these are we don't have to get into to
sort of too deep into these but like
EMDR sort of the standard today for
getting around PTSD and it deals with
it's it's a little complicated so it's
will let people google that okay but
that was all you know release and i
didn't draw a distinction at that time
in my mind between release and surrender
and one night I was having dinner at my
hometown Peoria Illinois with my mom and
I was telling her where I was at and I
was telling her I was kind of frustrated
with the research and I've hit this
limit and you know I've been able to
take people so far in terms of their
well-being but then they just sort of
plateaued they kind of hit this wall and
you would sort of even go back down in
well-being and it was like a huge
setback from a research standpoint for
me and she's like and she basically said
it was so cute she was like well honey
release is not the same thing as
surrender and it was just like and then
I found out
she experienced fundamental well-being
and she thought everybody did she is
Christian she's very Christian yeah and
when she asked Jesus to come into her
heart she had this profound
transformation the mom had the profound
transformation when she asked Jesus to
come into her heart you know and so she
just had this expectation that when she
went to church everybody who had ever
asked Jesus to come into their heart if
you think about it they're all praying
the same prayer singing the same so it
sounds kind of like everybody
experiences it she didn't realize that
she was like one of the lucky you know
0.25% or something that had a profound
sort of transformation and that her mom
was lucky too and so she thought when I
was living in Hong Kong at age 4 or
whatever and we were driving up the hill
to go to our place when I said mommy you
know I'd like to ask Jesus to come into
my heart she just assumed that like from
age 4 on I had the same thing she had
you know and then everybody had this
thing that was a Christian and whatever
else she didn't you know the academic
research we call it a successful
conversion experience it's when you have
something like would see it right it was
a term from 100 plus years ago totally
versus just being able to have all that
is be right there with you in your heart
and and that's you know your number it's
point two five percent one out of 400
people that seems like a crazy that
that's and so this so the swords
surrender so you're getting to the
fundamental well-being plateau let's
there at the wall and then the word
surrender will give to you the
continuation totally just opened up this
whole of the way of thinking and I just
hit me like a ton of bricks I was like
oh my god of course that's it we have we
totally do with our moms yes you're on
your thoughts like a ton of bricks
come on okay now okay so so I want to
show some of the images that we have of
you also being with here you're actually
you're doing two things you're not only
are you logging what they're
experiencing in a written
and an oral way but you're also taking
neural activity with EGS and what are
you finding when you're dealing with the
states of fundamental well-being and the
neural activity that's a great question
and what we basically find is there's a
kind of a reorganization of the brain
you would think of it that way right so
if you think about modern neuroscience
there's a lot of talk about networks in
the brain and you've got sort of these
hub regions and you know when one place
lights up and other place lights up and
together they form this network and
maybe there's another network that's
quiet when this network is active and
the dissolving of the default mode
network and so what we're finding is
like sort of new connections you know
some connections sort of atrophying
other connections coming online and you
can find that with EEG work and you can
find that with fMRI work I'm not an fMRI
person but we've collaborated with a
bunch of fMRI people over the years and
the for these things are all very deep
in the brain these are very very deep
regions what we call regions of interest
in the brain and so that prevented a lot
of progress really for many many years
because if you don't have an fMRI
machine that has real-time feedback
capability where you can sort of take a
picture of your brain and circle a spot
and then like put a bar on a screen and
say okay make the bar go up you know
when you finally figure out magically
somehow how to make the bar go up you
increase or decrease activity whatever
the bar is set to do you know to provide
feedback for you for if you think about
that that is like you know impossible
for you to get access to right for the
average person like how are they really
going to get access to that type of
equipment especially back then when we
were starting around 2008 2009 2010
there weren't that many systems that
were even set up for that they were very
very rare they were booked solid by
researchers you know all of that but
even with eg you've got to have a really
high density amount of electrodes that
we call you know basically a lot of
electrodes on the head so as much as I
love trans tech products like muse and I
think muse is amazing they push the
window you know forward and they've
basically got a for electro deg
to do the kind of stuff we need it's got
to kind of look like what's on the
screen right now and this is 48 this is
that's a 64 64 channel 64 is the minimum
is the minimum and if we were just
targeting one area we could just shorten
it down to maybe 30 you know and just
pick the right 30 that could triangulate
one spot but we don't need that and so
you know nobody's gonna know I mean you
can barely put this thing on your head
yourself if you try right there are a
few people at like the companies that
make them that have gotten good over the
years of putting these things on
themselves just to test the units or
whatever but I mean realistically you
gotta have somebody put the thing on you
you know you've got to have somebody
running the software oh yeah it's it's a
thing you need conductive gel you need
to get the lecture near the actual skin
past the hair and these are we use alien
headsets and so you saline yeah as a
solution before channel headset with Joe
research subjects don't come back you
know you know practical importance for
us to have a saline based headset system
that you know you could pop the headset
off a picture like that for a woman like
that and she could basically go back to
work you know she could just poof her
hair back up a little bit and whereas if
that was Joe I mean she'd have to go
home Joe shower or you know be cursing
your name the whole time so what are
some of the the realizations about the
state of fundamental well-being there's
this there's this voice that happens in
our head so you teach us about this yeah
my my coat you know my really my partner
in the trance text-based Nicole Bradley
loved Nicole yes came up with the best
way of saying that she's very good at
sort of plain spoken English stuff and
she one day she was like you know that
voice in your head that you know let me
ask you if I were to say I can take that
voice for you and I can transplant it
into another person and then I can make
it so that you are stuck in an elevator
for a long time with that person would
you want that of course most people are
like God the last thing that I would
want to experience because that voice is
usually quite negative you know it's
like sure have the desert tonight and
then oh look at what a horrible person
you are when you get on the scale the
next day you know and it's like it's
just so sort of schizophrenic and mean
yeah in most people's heads right and so
the last thing they would want to do is
be stuck at Cannella ironically like we
are kind of stuck and elevated with this
thing all the time right
so she identified very early on like
this is the thing to talk about like
this is the thing that everybody can
sympathize with you know and if you say
to them listen I can get rid of that
voice or at least massively minimize its
impact on you to the point where it's
like the fan running in the background
you know that we can sort of hear in the
studio right now but you know unless
until I say the fan running in the
background in the studio you weren't
listening to it you know nobody's
nobody's really hearing it's just
ignored in the background so you know
imagine if the voice can sort of become
that I mean talk about a massive
difference in your quality of life and
so she's been very good over the years
it's sort of like picking out these
things that you know are key things that
somebody would go how do I get that what
do we see at a neural activity level
when someone is you know just
fundamentally okay with their voice it
depends so there's different types of
measurements that you can do you can
measure frequency things and you can
measure blood flow things yeah and stuff
like that one way to think about it we
can talk about let's talk about blood
flow because that's like generally
talking about activation in the brain it
doesn't get into like crazy nitty-gritty
stuff around this frequency band versus
that frequency band all of that kind of
stuff so if you think about just
activation you basically get a reduced
activation and
hub of what you mentioned earlier which
is the default mode Network for anybody
doesn't know what that is it's basically
the network that's active when you're
sort of just sitting around doing
nothing and that's actually how it was
discovered there was somebody at in st.
Louis at a university who was like hey
let's look at the that the data that we
collected for people that are just
laying there waiting for an experiment
to begin right there's just all this
data nobody's ever really looked at it
before let's see what that data looks
like and it turns out that there was a
sort of network and this alternating
network between a task and default
networks that came out of that and so
the task network great name really easy
to see what the task network might be
active during right typically some of
the prefrontal activity for tasks for
yeah yeah these are very different
networks in the brain the test network
doesn't relate too much to PN se but the
Tor fundamental well-being yeah and I
see academic term for this yeah but the
the default Network really does and the
nodes of the default network the two
main ones really are there's one of them
been sort of between the hemispheres of
your brain in the front what we would
call the medial prefrontal cortex and
there's one in the back sort of right
back here between the again buried sort
of deep in there called the posterior
cingulate cortex and there's other
changes you know there's changes that
occur in an area of the brain called the
insula and you know things like that to
the retro Spoleto cortex which is a
little bit further and past the PCC so
there's there's a bunch of different
places that change and they change
differentially based on the type of
experience the type of fundamental well
being someone's having these different
types of this experience it's very
common for traditions to insist there's
just this experience or whatever right
I've just gotten into gotten traditions
at war with each other and even people
within traditions sort of it war with
each other but anyway so the main thing
that happens is reductions in activity
around some of these key nodes on the
default network and part of that is
because the default network seems to
relate among me
other things seems to relate to that
narrative individualized traditional
egoic whatever you want to call it sense
of self and so probably makes sense that
when that gets a little quieter
so does that version of the sense of
self so that's a that's a big finding
but then the other big finding was
really from a guy named Zoran you see
povitch at NYU and he was he was the
first one to really find the rewiring
that occurred and so he was looking at
non dual tibetan meditators and that was
a huge huge finding yeah ordinarily when
the task networking up the default
network is down and vice versa and I
sort of go like this and he was like
well in these people you know when
they're in this non-dual state it's like
a little closer together and that
shouldn't really have been possible as
people were thinking about these
networks at the time and so it was
really a revolutionary finding and then
you had people like Judd Brewer and
Zoran and others who focused more on
specific regions of the brain like judge
really loved the PCC he was a strong
advocate for the PCC is where it's at
built a neurofeedback system involving
the PCC with I think he I can't quite
remember I thought my head I think he
got it down to maybe 30 electrodes or
something just hit that one spot very
precisely it's deep in the brain it's
hard to get to it's a lot of physics and
math and stuff to really sort of get in
there yeah and so you know there's been
lots of efforts like this over the years
it's going to get much easier to be able
to map these states of fundamental
well-being once our our neuro technology
gets yeah yeah better imagine somebody
like Mary Lou Jepsen's things becoming
real I mean you know these technologies
that seem to be real comers it's going
to be incredible and this year we've
been experimenting with transcranial
ultrasound right which is another really
amazing technology this is the first
time that we've had a brain stimulation
technology that can just sort of reach
right in and just sort of tickle things
like the PCC we're tickling this not
suppress activity increase
you know whatever but just that spot and
not affect a bunch of brain going in and
out and all of that but just be like
okay you know this little spot right
here boom right so that's been
revolutionary for the last year or so
okay we need to talk about these
locations now types these I was okay the
types okay we call the locations okay
because there's a continuum of possible
experiences and within this fundamental
well being and this everything from a
state of being fundamentally okay
the silence and stillness of the mind a
present moment focused at dis attachment
from stories to being less reactive
being having a lesson narrative self
you're becoming less psychologically
conditioned yeah for sure
and/or a condition differently or we
could yeah condition differently
condition towards that fundamental
okayness right and and this is probably
most easily understood through what so
many of the meditation practices teach
of of being able to have a period of
cognition rather than the immediate
reaction to some to a stimuli sure yeah
much less reactive absolutely yeah so
you're you're you're less with the
condition psychology that you've had of
immediately reacting to something versus
taking a breath sitting back right
curving exactly and yeah you know if we
walk through these if you think about so
we call them locations on a continuum we
think about a number line it's kind of a
continuum because it seems like we're
we're talking about the same thing it's
all somewhere in the family of
well-being experiences right and so then
it's but there are clearly different
types there's clearly very different
ways of experiencing this stuff and so I
didn't want to be in a situation where
there was like you're in level three but
I'm only in level two right alright so I
wanted to avoid that type of thing
because I don't think that's legitimate
I mean it might be legitimate in terms
of the depth of fundamental well-being
you're in but you know so what right I
mean being more relaxed is let's just
take it outside a fundamental well being
let's say this continuum of relaxation
right well for some people like let's
say I'm retired right and you know maybe
I'm getting into my late 80s like my dad
is or whatever right yeah it's okay for
me to sit around a deep relaxation all
day long right on the other hand if I'm
a firefighter and I'm still working you
know is a state of deep relaxation
what's most appropriate for my life in
all moments and times right and so why
should you say well gosh I'm so sorry
that you're only at a level two of
relaxation yeah that's oh man I can
there's level four man yeah you should
get to level four it's amazing the
relaxation of level four right and
you're like well yeah but I'm gonna burn
to the ground fighting a fire if I'm in
you know level four of relax a doesn't
fit my life right and so that's really
what we saw as we were looking at these
different types is that it was just
really clear that some were way more
appropriate for certain life and certain
lifestyles and certain cultures even you
know belief systems and whatever else
and other ones were and so I thought
okay we cannot have this be some sort of
reinforced hierarchy like has been done
over millennia and then you start
thinking yourself how do i how do I get
around that right and so we call them
buckets at first just be very generic
but then people couldn't sort of
visualize them as one thing they
visualized it was like these separate
sort of buckets you know that we're
sitting out there so eventually we came
up with the idea okay it's all one
continuum it's all sort of one thing but
they're just like a number line they're
sort of them one number isn't you know
number three isn't better than number
two or number seven whatever else unless
you're maybe into numerology or
something but with the where exception
or something like that right so the one
that's heavily doing tasks and focused
on tasks can find themselves potentially
doing one of these deep dives into a
into a state of fundamental well-being
if possible and that can actually make
your tasks much more effective I can but
it depends on the task
and it depends on the matching of that
task right and so let's go through them
real quick and direct you to some of
those may be examples of that type of
thing right so if you think about
location one which is the furthest left
on a number line right and sort of the
starting point if you will a fundamental
well being but having said that you can
start anywhere so people do not start
just one there you know in our very
first experiment where we're
transitioning people to this trying to
get a B data not just B data you know
not just after the person was their data
which is what we got for a long time but
trying to really measure like okay
what's the before and what's the after
for these people so we the first
experiment that we did with six people
five alone finished one of the people
who finished landed in the fourth
category of this the fourth location of
this from nothing right I mean they
never meditated no frame of reference
necessarily for any of this and it was
just like four and so that's a great
example that his name is Paul and Paul's
a great example of how anybody can sort
of pop into any one of these as their
starting point and the starting point
can be the finishing point they can stay
in that location forever and that's
totally fine
right so no judgment around any of this
but just to say location one is the
furthest left it's the you know maybe
the most simple of them all to to talk
about and describe the thing about
location one that you look for more than
anything else and it's going to be true
across the whole thing is does someone
have a fundamental sense that things are
ok so all of us you know we are raised
culturally I don't know if it's DNA I
don't know what it is but for some
reason the average human regardless of
seemingly of where they are on the
planet has this fundamental sense of
discontentment at their core not a
fundamental sense of contentment
certainly that was true of me you know
it's true of if basically if you're not
in fundamental well-being it's true for
you I'm trying to find some meaning in
our lives can be can express itself as a
need for meaning and purpose think about
the purpose movement and how like all
you have to do is say I'm doing a
conference on purpose and like four
trillion people show up these days right
because like everybody seems to be like
searching for their meaning and their
purpose or whatever right it could be
that it could also just be simple goal
stuff I was in the mid nineties it
early nineties and stuff I was doing a
lot of advertising stuff and so you know
we just poked on that like there was no
tomorrow you know it's like you we that
sort of god-sized hole that everybody
has in them whether they're looking at
it or not it's immensely useful from a
net it's the entire basis of modern
advertising and marketing and stuff
right and so it's like you know buying
to fill the hole yeah buy to fill the
hole right it's the it's the next
Chevrolet that's gonna finally fill that
for you beer whatever is right that's
what a lot of what our mind does a lot
of what sort of that narrative sense of
self does it's constantly trying to
convince you that oh okay yeah that
relationship didn't work out wasn't that
one I was wrong on that one and I was
wrong on the fifty that came before it
but but now I understand I've learned
from those 50 and who you're looking for
next time is this right or whatever else
of course yeah I mean maybe you have an
amazing relationship but it still
doesn't fill that fundamental sense of
sort of discontentment right and then
that fundamental sense of just content
me could argue is evolutionary it's like
you know keeps you alive you know we do
when a bird lands and you're eating
outside and you throw it a crumb
it doesn't just like peck at the crime
and then be like oh man this crumb is so
good and just like wait for something to
swoop down and kill it it's like peck at
the crumb okay what's wrong it's gonna
try to kill me all right pick up the
crumb that's gonna kind of kill me right
I mean we're all animals we've all sort
of got that same sort of besides your
house dog and cat them know they're safe
all the time if you watch animals in the
wild they're completely oh just
everything good okay cool okay just
shanghaied into modern life right and so
when your boss says you're fired or you
know your spouse comes home and says I'm
divorcing you or whatever it feels like
the end of the world feels like the
tiger ripping your arm off right like
these modern stories have hijacked those
neural processes and stuff so anyway
that changes with location one and you
get this fundamental sense of
discontentment replaced with a
fundamental sense of contentment and the
benefit of that is
that that's what's basically laying the
foundation for your moment-to-moment
experience in the world and you can
imagine that's a night and day
difference right yeah it's like as
you're commuting to work or as you're
you're you're taking it in you're taking
in being alive as a human and being
amongst other humans and in the
privileged society that we have were
water so easily accessible these types
of thought processes and gratitude for
your parents and for your life and all
this yeah why should I be afraid of
something right now you know I mean
what's gonna burst through the door of
the studio and just you know and I guess
we are alive maybe I've offended we're
trying to lose weight right not worried
about starving before we make it to our
next berry bush or catch our next fish
or you know whatever it is I mean I walk
outside this building and you're like
the epicenter one of the epicenters of
San Francisco or I'm gonna walk by an
infinite amount of calories in between
here in my car right and so it's just it
doesn't make sense right so the other
thing hasn't happen with location one is
there's a drop-off in terms of how long
they get of emotions last you know you
might die because you know you're not
you know just have this positive
negative emotion thing go away right I
mean you're not just like everything's
okay look it's just peace and
contentment all the time in location one
you still have this you know it's a very
important point they say that yeah it's
that you still end up feeling negative
stimuli but they don't dwell on for
hours yeah yeah three days later you're
not still thinking about the guy that
cut you off in traffic and almost you
know risk your kids life that was in the
passenger seat and you know pondering
the photograph you took up their license
plate and what you can do with it and
you know all of these things that sort
of are actually not that uncommon you
going to think about social science so
yeah when you're when your wife says to
you or your husband says to you I'm
leaving you you're not like okay you are
leaving me
I understand I understand it's Rory and
this moment there is nothing right I
mean you're like you feel the like oh my
you might feel it think to yourself
thank god that's over right or you might
think to yourself oh man
this shoot right but if you in that
moment look down deep there is that
fundamental sight and it's an improbable
sense of contentment you're like why in
the world would I be feeling like things
are okay somehow strangely bizarrely at
a deep level things seem okay like like
that's my entire world is falling apart
at this level up here right why in the
world would I have this experience that
somehow fundamentally things are okay
right and it's a kind of a paradoxical
could II think that the greatest
treasures are on the other side of some
of these deep most deep adversities to
our face or that it just doesn't really
you know most of the things that matter
to you don't matter that much you know
at the end it's tough to you know we're
programmed in to have them to think that
they matter a lot more than they really
do or or whatever and so there's a
quieting in the narrative sense of self
is a reduction in self referential
thoughts in location one but these are
the big things right then location to
the main thing that you look for in
location two is a perceptual shift that
is popularly called non-duality right so
if anybody googles non-duality while
they're listening to this and certainly
it's probably playing in a tab in the
background or something at this point
right and so just you know open another
tab and search the Google or non-duality
if you'd like but basically it's a it's
it's a sense of oneness it's one way
that things can show up in a sense of
oneness
so like I'm experiencing non-duality
right now it doesn't and it's very
paradoxical to try to describe to people
right because it really genuinely
doesn't feel like there's a difference
between me and you I get that I'm
experiencing my senses not your senses
right and yet you don't seem different
then it just seems like there's just
this one thing the one thing and so it's
it's it's very hard to explain to
somebody that doesn't experience it
because they think that well then you
should be feeling the other person's
senses if you're really just showing
this thing
showing up as one thing or whatever also
there's a lot of sort of paradox around
it and to me you know I'm a brain
scientist so I think to myself well I
can see how you can rewire a few things
in the brain you get to the sense that
it feels like this and well if somebody
is listening to this in another tab
right now or possibly even watching it
whoa
the single task single task is God we
love love you you know something that
they can do to act to ask themselves
well how do I know if I experience this
don't experience this it's actually
quite simple just ask yourself as you're
looking right now how is that experience
of looking and I don't mean that it's in
a metaphorical way or where I'm just
like literally as concretely as you can
think of those words what is it like to
look right now and so if you if it feels
like there's something like in and
around here that's like looking like I'm
sitting here looking at you it's like I
am here and there's a clear looking and
there's something in here that's seeing
you and you're out there and I'm here
not so much in the non-dual yeah service
space right but if you're if I open my
eyes and it's just sort of all here it
doesn't feel like there's this looker
then there's transits you might be
experiencing that same thing with
hearing is there a listener or is it all
just like oh it's all just sort of
showing up and it seems like it's just
one thing and whatever and many people
experience this many more people
experience this than no they experience
it but culture doesn't sit around
talking about these types of perceptual
changes these types of a perceptual
experiences so people just don't realize
another way of potentially proceeding
this would be all the way full circle
back to what we started talking about
when we said eight billion perspectives
it's like and when you're here in this
room with Ron and Jeffrey am I am I also
you at the same time in my in the room
at the same time can I take my
consciousness above San Francisco
can I start feeling San Francisco all at
the same time can I start feeling the
earth all at the same time and so this
is a non dual approach to perception and
took and to experience the qualia yeah
it does seem not so much in location to
and later locations especially there are
non-dual it does feel like there's some
sort of like okay and it kind of makes
sense right if you are if we really are
just part of this one
and really how could we not be so if we
are really just part of this one thing
why shouldn't I be able to sense beyond
just my immediate physiological senses
right so location to further reduction
and self referential thoughts you know
by the you know by the time you're
really deep in it it's mostly a positive
emotional experience still have emotions
still have a sense of agency still feel
like you can do things still feel like
you're making choices all of that
location3 the big hallmark is a big
shift in emotion to a sense a location3
has started the end of the classic
Abrahamic mystical traditions it's you
know where Sufis try to get mystical
Christians try to get those also
reflections of this in Buddhism and
Hinduism and stuff but most people in
America that listen to English podcasts
have a Christian background and so I
think it's helpful to say well this is
sort of what the Christian mystics try
to get into us location3 and it really
it's dual again actually it's very
subtly dual again because you have this
sense that you're in merger or union
with something else it's a divine if
it's Christian religiously so the dual
comes back so that there's a communion
with this yeah I mean how could I feel
like I'm increasingly merging into
something if it's all one it's all one
why would I ever have that experience
right so there's some sort of coming out
of that non-dual experience and then
going back into it and location for and
then there's that one core emotion that
you experience in location three which
feels like a like impersonal or divine
love compassion joy and it can't have
more than facets than that
sort of but it's like it's it's the
dominant thing it's the dominant emotion
that's with you if you're if your
parents die or something I mean you're
gonna feel a little something come up in
that right it's not necessarily a
totally 24/7 always on nonstop into the
world comes kind of you know you're
starving kind of thing but for the most
part for the average person's life it's
a consistent ongoing experience barring
major catastrophes you know that
happened to them and usually one of
those facets is more front and center at
any given time so I might be feeling
more love or more joy or more
or more whatever the other ones are that
were culturally programmed into me along
those lines
some people experience the divine some
people experience it more from a pen
psycho sense which is a philosophical
term that basically means like
everything is conscious or everything
feels like it's consciousness or
whatever else and so some people of the
merging into that some people have the
merging into the divine I don't I've
never felt as far as I know anything
that feels divine so I have like the pan
psychist version of that when I'm in
locations means further reduction in
self referential thoughts or thus alien
sea of self referential thoughts and
these two divine and pants I presume
almost come together a little bit into
the all that is that kind of yeah and
they're both they're both impersonal
right that's the key thing about it it's
not a personal love it's not a personal
joy it's not you know they both they're
both basically an impersonal sense of
these things yeah and we can also kind
of feel that we're probably most
commonly when you're like in the in the
cuddles of your partner when you're when
you're just and it just feels ethereal
that it's just so profoundly love and
compassion and bliss that you're just
laying there next to each other
in the quiet together now that can also
pay for ordinary people the height of
the personal version of that yeah that's
not a dis person over that's right
depends on where you're at on the
continuum yeah yeah and then location
for it feels like you've just sort of
fallen off a cliff into an alien world
features about this so their sense of
agency goes away often you know you feel
like you can't take a decision you know
there's no there is no decision-maker
there is no action that and it's
paradoxical right because you're sitting
there interviewing someone and they're
clearly like I'll have the lemongrass
chicken right you're like AHA that's a
decision there was no decision was made
there you know yeah it just feels like
it's just the synchronous thing
unfolding action is happening decisions
seem to be being made but internally and
in one's experience of this these things
are just unfolding it's like the sort of
the universe continuing to unfold you're
sort of watching it it's fascinating you
know
it's a fascinating interior experience
no sense of emotion even love it goes at
that point and that's what partially
brings the alien alien feeling to it I
often say location 3 if you look at the
mystical literature the Mystics and
stuff why we haven't read a lot of
mystical literature so I only know what
they tell me I used to only sit down
with real people they only research real
people I don't want to know I don't want
to have to guess what somebody meant by
some sentence in a book I want to be
able to ask you for however many hours I
need to ask you until I'm sure I
understand the sentence that just came
out of your mouth right but needless to
say lots of people use lots of
references over the years that resonated
with them from different traditions that
we interviewed people in and their books
and their scriptures and all that so one
of the things that's interesting about
location for from that from that sort of
know emotional standpoint is that it
goes along with this sense of a complete
absence of needing approval from other
people like so the the word you look for
in location for out of people's mouths
is freedom it's like everybody has the
same word
well location for it's like you know
location 3 is awesome it's probably the
peak of classical human experience right
yeah and then location 4 feels like
you've fallen off into this alien
landscape but you are more free for you
on a scale that was unimaginable at any
previous location yes this is just very
fascinating ok these locations yeah the
books fantastic the finders ok so this
this is actually this is this is so so
cool so all right let's let's take a
let's take an example of something like
like a free will that this under
conversation by philosophers so
frequently neuroscientists even so then
in in a location for there is no yeah
there's the notion of free will is
ludicrous you know if you're arguing
with somebody in location for about free
well they're just going to think you
an infant really that just doesn't
understand the way things really really
are now interesting past location for
you know there are more locations beyond
that it just keeps getting fewer and
fewer and fewer people obviously who
experienced these the further you go
but then there's kind of a fork in the
road and some people that go past
location for kind of return to a more of
a human ish experience worth some forms
of love obviously completely impersonal
forms and so you know come back in and
in those instances you can have sort of
a difference in freewill there can be
some beliefs that come back and around
freewill or some some experiences of
doubt around well maybe there really is
some sort of freewill here and then on
the other side it looks just like
location for to the increasing max right
and like those you know that I call that
the path of freedom the other one the
path of humanity if you're on the path
of freedom like you're never gonna argue
with pro freewill okay like free will is
in the past you know in terms of your
experience of moment-to-moment existence
not from a philosophical stance off
achill debates to people these are how
their lived experience is showing up for
them yes that they're talking about this
and i think it's important for people to
realize if they read these people's
books and stuff like that and they're
interested in watching their videos and
all of that oftentimes people will say
things like you know i what it was like
waking up from a dream or they'll have
their have these phrases and and when I
was first sitting down with him I was
thinking the way other people I've
noticed over the years think about this
and I was thinking oh these are like
metaphors they're like trying to give me
a metaphor that you notice but it's
they're really not most people are
trying to give you as close an analogy
and your actual lived experience as they
are experiencing and their lived
experience yeah and so it's you know you
can't think of it as a metaphorical type
attempt at communication you have to
think of it as a literal type of
communication they're really trying to
get you to as literal the realization as
close as they think you probably have
experienced in your life to what it is
that they've actually experienced that's
a that's a mistake I think a lot of
people make in terms of interpreting
these types
people's you know statements because
they're not in the stories they're not
into metaphor some of them train
themselves to be good at it again so
that they can build some large audience
or because they're in some venerated
position in some spiritual tradition and
they're just stuck with thousands or
millions or tens of millions of
adherents or whatever right and so
they've just got a soar to go back into
it in the same way that a programmer has
to go back to work after one of these
experiences even though they might not
want to be thinking in algorithms right
away or you know whatever else right so
anyways yeah all this okay and then is
the the location five this deep
disassembly and reassembly yeah five six
pretty much five up you know you it's
your good so deep into the architecture
of the I think of it you know again it's
the neuroscientists bias in perspective
for me right I think of it as you've dug
so deep into your wiring so deep into
your connections and you've gotten rid
of so much of your connections that that
constructed sort of what most people
think of as the normal sense of self the
societally accepted condition sort of
you know so you can be like everybody
else and fit in kind of sense of self
you've deconstructed so much of that
that you've been constructing probably
since age two and a half or something on
but eventually you get down to the point
you know what comes before - right I
mean when you're out of the womb or when
you're in the womb or I mean it's just
like your brain just learning how your
senses work how they go together how you
know how wake-sleep works I mean there's
like some early stuff that is kind of
learned as part of the developmental
process by the brain by the nervous
system whatever else eventually you kind
of are reaching back into those really
super early days and it can get
dangerous you know I can get very
dangerous you can get some glitches that
I don't haven't traditionally talked
much about location five six seven eight
nine so on because you know I think
they're they can be dangerous too to go
for outside of a support system that
knows how to deal with the deep surgical
operation into the
first two years of life or the woven
certain to the deepest yes circuitries
and being able to to come out in a
reassembled form that is a that
transcends experience and it's like kind
of crazy yeah yeah exactly yeah it's a
it's unbelievable like the restructuring
that cat that can occur at those deeper
levels and then you actually literally
can feel yourself be less
psychologically conditioned to those
roots that for sure lengthen and did a
search cooperation on yeah absolutely
and then that's when you really realize
the power that you also have in changing
your own life in your own felt
experience if you're willing to explore
and how many different experiences there
are of the world all through this as
well you know I mean when you start
getting into that five through nine
range you start having a lot more
reports of sigh especially on the path
of freedom less so on the path of
humanity sigh sigh you know psychic
activity and you know people like
psychic premonitions really accurate
intuition all of sort of those sorts of
things right you get past location 9 and
you start having reports of you know
mind matter interaction type stuff from
people and I have to be careful of all
that because I'm not a magician
you know that I haven't made like some
careful study of all of that but I can
collect reports and you can you know you
can respect someone's sense that and
especially a highly functional person's
sense you know if I feel like we must
then talk to you about this once you get
so far on these you know on this
continuum of locations does it then feel
as though we come from somewhere that is
not this 3d reality into the playground
that is earth
it's difficult to think of how to define
that type of thing right like by a
location 9 the thing that I look for
around location and you hear it earlier
but you hear it in a less complete form
but at location 9 there's just like the
solid sense from people and they just
they like the phrase it's just the
universe looking out my eyes right so
there's been so much deconditioning of
that individualized sense of self and so
much deconstruction of that
individualized sense of self but the way
that they feel that they can best
express it it doesn't matter the culture
you're in you know doesn't matter the
degree of sophistication or education of
the person like you basically hear the
same phrase out of people in location 9
and it's you know it just feels like the
universe looking at my eyes and you
might hear that location 8 you might
hear that location 7 but it's slightly
different you know when you dig into
it's colored a little bit there'll be a
writer on it there uh yeah you know it
just feels like it's the universe
looking out my eyes and or but or you
know there'll be some sort of context
provided around that statement that
context is just gone right by location 9
so is that you know is that still part
of the the physical game or sort of the
you know is the universe just sort of
are you still in the game that you were
talking about in your question a minute
ago or by that point is that what
they're referring to not what they're
referring to you know I think it's
probably impossible to know unless
you're actually experiencing that and
then you know if you think about people
that are that are reporting really
routine abilities to sort of mess with
you know mind matter interaction type
stuff manifest things and you know stuff
like that
which of course is not limited to this
population of people there's all kinds
of people who aren't in these you know
further locations and stuff that claim
to be able to do the same types of
things and that have been researched and
seen in some cases to be able to do them
at least the it's you know is that
I don't know I guess I questioned if if
this is all philosophical speculation
and these types of questions of course
right because how could we ever know if
we're outside of whatever this thing is
right probably you can never get outside
of whatever this thing is we probably
get to different layers of it levels of
it and it's probably like playing a
video game at its extreme right you may
be never outside the video game but by
the time you make it to level 390 level
one seemed something so simple and
primitive and you know concrete and you
know whatever I'll but that doesn't mean
that you've escaped the video game
totally or whatever else yeah still
baked into it and then but how do we
ever know you know essentially
potentially know by by recreating and
then observing potentially and then
making um making more embeds potentially
this maybe you're just playing with
lower levels in the game hanging planes
lower instead of being able to poke
scientifically at the higher yeah it's
it's the ultimate yeah remembering and
it's it's a bunch of
let's let's pecan on zooming in and out
I think this is this is very profound
the when when you're when you're finding
yourself just
relaxing or ice close there at the park
or wherever you are maybe and then all
of a sudden someone says your name
there's kind of a trigger in a sense of
you to zoom in on a conversation so
versus what you were doing before was
maybe a feeling of being like zoomed out
so can you speak on this yeah I think
that's a good way of thinking about it
from how a normal person might
conceptualize it if you think of that as
being another continuum if there's like
a zoomed in left side and a zoomed out
right side or you could flip them
doesn't matter what we're really talking
about fundamental well-being is
increasing access to further zoomed out
locations on that continuum and then
what that provides you in the zoomed and
experience in terms of perspective or in
terms of so they're less Lancaster who's
a researcher in the UK I just saw
speaking at a conference actually the
other day he had this great he noticed
these things that I think he called him
eye tags and this were in like the 80s
or early 90s or something where he wrote
a paper about this and what he was
noticing is that in sort of people that
were in people in finders essentially
that there were like these little senses
of self you know maybe hundreds of them
and someone and that well and they're
not just in Finers but they're really
sort of he believed that they're sort of
in every one they may very well be in
every one and so you know when when I
come up and I say your name and you're
sitting on that park bench which one of
those are you going to zoom into right
if you open your eyes and it's the
President of the United States and a
Secret Service detail it's maybe this
one right if it's your girlfriend maybe
this one that's right if it's your you
know if it's me maybe this one right
interesting one of those may cause you
to run my brother engaged yeah you know
another it's some more of your to
another be like honey I'm relaxing here
don't bother me right what you probably
wouldn't say to the president right I'd
probably be the one you ran from
but you know whichever one it turned out
to be right and so what what what he
sort of identified was that there
actually there's not this composite
construct of the self there's all kinds
of selves
yeah there seems to be a smoothing
function in our moment-to-moment
experience that denies us access to that
knowledge where it just feels like
there's this one sort of self and
there's you know I'm like this when I'm
with you and I'm like this other thing
when I'm with this other person and I'm
like this in them then then there was
the five year old me and somehow if you
think about it sort of if you just think
about it for a second it's kind of
insane
that we view this as one composite
construct that the five-year-old Jeffrey
Wright presumably Jeffy at that point it
is like the same so somehow be just
magically smeared in my brain to be
co-equal and the same as the version of
Jeffrey that's sitting here with you in
this interview versus the version that's
going to be back at the lab in an hour
or something or that was you know a
friend of mine caught me on the street
you happen to be near a art exhibit
that's going on with transformative
technology and stuff and he spotted me
from behind and he was walking back from
lunch or something or dinner it was like
Jeffrey you know I was three minutes
early and then 17 minutes late for this
interview it was amazing the version
that I am with him very different than
the version that I am with you
right and so les called these I tags
which I think was an interesting
conceptualization of his and we found
that with people that experience
fundamental well-being because there's
something about sort of the
deconstruction of that sense of self and
also something about the degree of being
able to zoom out and get a new level of
perspective where now you know when you
zoom in in fundamental well-being to
whatever degree you zoom into there's a
lot more awareness about the version of
you that you're zooming into you can
choose to zoom in lots of times to
different degrees of depth that becomes
automatic in some ways over time there's
like a new you know where the average
person on the park bench you open your
eyes you know there's that's all
automatic right
thinking yourself ok time to focus on
the president now hello mr. president
I'm increasingly focusing it it's just
automatic right you open your eyes oh
crap it's the president you know I hope
you didn't see my tweets or whatever
you're our man I like that person or you
know whatever the thought is that goes
through the average person's head right
we're from a fundamental well-being
standpoint you know you can you sort of
notice the role that you're adopting
you're more aware of it you can it's
there's an automaticity develops in that
over time there's a lack of self
referential thought of course and
fundamental well-being and that means
it's a lack of self-reflection which
means you know you you feel like you're
fine as you are right so you don't why
why I don't need self-help classes why
would I need a self up class I'm I'm
whole I'm fine I don't need to add
anything to myself I don't need to
change anything about myself right now
it could not be true I could be a
complete jerk to you you know coming
across to you for me if I'm like I'm
perfectly fine you know you leave the
interview and be like that guy's nuts
you know but I won't sense that
necessarily without some sort of
external feedback loop that you know
maybe by the time my 900th girlfriend
leaves me in a month or whatever may
okay maybe something's off maybe it's
not them right but so without that self
referential loop there isn't necessarily
a desire to act on these AI tags what is
calling my tags I don't use that term in
the book but we'll just use less those
terms
and change them some people in earlier
locations do have that degree of
awareness they do have enough self
referential thought remaining that
they're like wow this is really useful I
can tweak this one this way and this one
this other way and oh look they're all
kind of interconnected and when I change
this one a little bit it ripples through
changes these other ones that are sort
of like that one and boy this is a
really effective yeah self-improvement
program right by location for your like
we could call this developing out
awareness developing out awareness yeah
it's a new yeah exactly it's a new
automaticity a new development yes I'm
not sampling exactly yeah okay Wow I
feel I feel like you know we shouldn't
we should mention this right before we
ask your the couple quick questions on
the way out
an email it's support at finders course
comm and if if anyone is interested in
conversing with Jeffrey and the team of
the ones that are putting together this
material on the finders please reach out
again that support at finders course
comm yeah we were talking before the
interview and we're and I was saying it
would be interesting to see like how
many people listen to this podcast that
are like wow they're describing me yeah
you know so that's why we want to give
out that address like you're like if you
think you're if we just were curious to
know like how many people are out there
listening to this that are like oh
that's sounds really close to a
description of some way you know maybe
it's location two or four or whatever it
is and this would be a very good way to
potentially put piece together
communities of people that feel this way
and then then you don't feel so alone no
I think that's that's a crisis oriented
you don't feel lonely right but you feel
more isolated in the world that's the
key differential there yeah yeah
okay those types of people can also go
to explorers course comm we have a
two-hour free video thing that basically
gives them the most important things to
know if you're in this state of
consciousness lores course comm yeah you
just go it's free just register in two
hours of of key it's a bunch of little
videos but it adds up to about two hours
and it's the things that we felt if
you're a finder these are the things
that you should know that you probably
can't figure out unless you've talked
with thousands of finders and done
research on thousands of finders you
know what are the cycles that unfold in
your life for instance how do you know
as a finder for instance you privileged
piece right
I mean effectively in every moment it's
like that's right it's like you know I
have is the most important is the most
important yeah and I think until you say
that to som finders they haven't
necessarily put that together and it's
just helpful for a finder to hear that
and go wow that's yeah that is my main
operating mo right and so they're just
things like that I think it's helpful to
hear from an external perspective cycles
that we've learned about that you just
can't see unless
you're researching a large population
it's helpful to know about stuff like
that so we packed all that stuff out of
that couple hours it's great finders
course explorers explorers course
finders course is the experiment where
we transition people to to be finders
and explorers course is the content we
put out for people there's a fibers
course for transitioning to be finders
explores courses for those that are
finders that are coming in so those
links are in the bio everyone Jeffrey I
feel I feel really powerful and strong
right now and enlightened and I really
appreciate you coming on the show and
teaching us about the finders and yeah I
feel really good and I hope others do
too after watching the content or
listening to the content a couple quick
questions that we like to ask our guests
on the way out the first question is are
we alone in the cosmos
well it depends on the level of
consciousness you want me to answer that
from one thing technically I'm alone
right and so then it sort of goes
downhill from there into what level do
we really want to skin that at right on
the physical level you're probably out
there right there's probably you know
even though I experience this is just
one thing nonetheless I seem to be here
you seem to be there right he seems to
be over there and so you know then there
was a myriad of things that can be
discussed basically between those two
bookends right yeah yeah are do you
think we're in a simulation
I don't know simulation video game hey I
think there's I think it's easy for us
to feel that way but one of the hitches
that we I think have to keep in mind as
humans is that we're interpreting things
at any given time through our latest
idea of a framework right and so like
the until recently the brain was a
computer because computers were the most
advanced computational thing right and
so all neuroscientists sort of reviewing
the brain and writing papers about the
brain and designing our models of the
brain and whatever with the brain is a
computer and now we wouldn't really say
the brain is a computer like we've
evolved sort of beyond that now you have
like quantum consciousness things going
with some brain scientists and you know
other but it's we're all sort of we're
sort of stuck in the limit of metaphor
right and so you know can you adopt the
belief system that says you're in a
simulation or you're in a video game or
whatever else yes but on the other hand
if you're 100 years from now and there's
something way better than a video game
that seems to we'll probably say you're
in that I saw this one thing one time
I've never been able to find it again
but there was one of these UFO societies
put out some newsletter or something and
it was sitting on a friend of Mines
coffee table 25-30 years ago another
friend of other engineer from NBC back
when I was working in and television and
I I was waiting for him he's like having
some problems with kids or something I
was just sitting around waiting for him
and I have some looking for something to
read because my mind was really active
back then had to be constantly fed right
and so here's this UFO thing okay I want
flipping through the UFO thing I had
this story about that basically tracked
people's views of UFOs over time and
there were like woodcuts from like I
don't know 17th century newspapers or I
don't what I don't know something like
that right I'm not a great historian in
terms of the printing press or anything
where it was like people would see like
tall ships in the sky right and then it
was it was almost like this guy had sort
of documented culturally how like you
know when sauce went flying saucers came
in and it's like flying saucers and you
know it's like I think we all have to
sort of keep in mind
our brains are shaped by these types of
notions you know so yeah it does it feel
to me in this moment like it's some sort
I mean reality does not feel that real
reality reality does not feel like it's
concrete like people like I felt it was
before fundamental well-being yeah right
for sure but a house will have to say
we're probably going to come up with
something much better than the notion of
a simulation in 50 years or 25 years or
100 years or so so who knows what will
say is you know sure and then the last
question is what is the most beautiful
thing in the world
I don't think it had I don't I don't
think there's a way to answer that
because I'm not sure that you can
express it in language it's everything
right it's sort of the composite of
everything right like your microphone
clip is the most beautiful thing in the
world that's what I'm focusing on or and
so it's it's you know
I don't know it's if it's if I'm sitting
alone in silence its silence can be the
most beautiful thing in the world if I'm
looking in your eyes right now they can
be the most beautiful thing in the world
right I don't know that there's a
differentiation there it's sort of like
whatever my attention is on let me get
the on yes the most for maybe that's the
answer yeah that's a good good answer
yeah yeah I like that one a lot
wherever the attention is being focused
at that moments the most beautiful thing
in the world now Jeffery sorry I missed
you at the conference well look at how
much more you know big ass yeah yeah and
I've had more time to build out my
structures of perception and reasoning
so and you and the finders came out it
is great timing everyone check out the
Finder is the links below for that check
out Jeffrey's website also remember if
you if these experiences felt something
like something that you experienced what
we've been describing email support at
finders course.com huge shout out to ron
vargas thank you very much for producing
and directing like you're on we love you
very much thank you
and thanks everyone for tuning in give
us your thoughts in the comments below
we would love to hear from you we would
also love for you to share these types
of conversations with more people go and
talk to your family and your friends
your community's online about these
conversations that we were having today
with Jeffrey and also support the
artists and entrepreneurs and
organizations that you believe in around
the world to help people with their
actualization simulations links are
below help support us help us grow and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you so much thank you for tuning in
and we will see you soon peace
[Music]